Linda is what you might call an
unreliable narrator and that their
versions of her story that are at odds
with other people's versions of her
story and I'm curious as you're starting
to work on this film versions of her
story that are at odds with her own
story that's true there's versions upon
versions as you're starting to work on a
film like this when there's so many
conflicting points of view how do you
decide what that point of view is going
to be or do you decide there's gonna be
multiple points of view well ultimately
that's what we decided we wanted to find
a story structure that would allow for
different tellings of the same story
because that's how she presented it so
we wanted to first present the story as
she publicly presented it and as in
early a lot of biographies that's how
she wrote about it and then pulled back
the curtain coming for and documentary
helped us be free with the structure
because we're very used to taking real
events and structuring them in in in you
know in different dramatic forms
depending on what we're trying to what
we're trying to accomplish there's a
great documentary on the subject inside
deep throat so we felt like that had
been covered in the documentary arena
Linda Lovelace is a is a it's a
household name I was born in the mid 80s
why would I have known who who she was
or what she represented but I did I had
this idea of her and I know I know this
movie the script was bouncing around and
I was intrigued and then I I did I
finally did get to read it and I mean
your idea of her is nothing like her
real story and it's it's disturbing how
what she really did go through and I
thought wow this is just you got to
change the audience's perspective I mean
every every generation people that that
did experience deep throat and the so
called sexual revolution and and all
that I think it's just every it's just
shocking for for it for anybody as soon
as I met Robin Jeff I
I just I trusted them they have just so
much integrity and they and they really
right off the bat said that I wanted we
want to tell her story from her
perspective and that makes everything so
like all that more simple for me because
I know that that's I'm only really just
gonna embody her and believe in her just
like they believe in her and and you
just start off from there
so I mean it they made it pretty easy
for me to just jump on board Sharon were
you in this movie I mean that as a
compliment
yes people say that to me I thought you
were in that movie yes I get to play her
mother which is very very exciting for
me it's and it's amazing when you
research a character who's a it was a
true figure how much you can find when
you fare it around and and look of
course online you know you can find out
anything its seemingly about anyone and
yes because there were things in in
Linda's book and there were there were
just pictures and and things online and
these marvelous gentleman brought me
things so and then as we began to
develop the character and decide how we
were going to get this impression of the
character you know it's it's that that
thing when you make a decision are we
going to try to impersonate the
character we tried and get it just an
impression of the character and I felt
that this construct of creating this
impression of the character was a very
wise way to go because with that you
sort of do a little bit less in the
facade and you bring it forth from
inside which is what which is what Robin
Jeff encouraged me to do and and I was
grateful for that in the end scared in
the beginning great scared of the part
or scared well no wasn't scared of the
part I understood the because for from
where the mothers coming from it's the
it's the story of her
relationship with her daughter and her
husband and this this thing about you
know this dysfunctional family cycle
where she comes from something that's
been very hard in her past
it passes on through her to her daughter
and her daughter finally has the courage
to stand up and break that wheel of
dysfunction and abuse and a family cycle
and and she's ultimately of course very
proud of her daughter and and sees at a
point oh my god this is really what's
happened and is happening and here's my
piece in it heavily interview driven and
you're directing the interviews when
you're when you're interviewing people
you're trying to get you know you're
trying to get something from them and
you're trying to get some something
spontaneous something real to happen and
that's the same thing you're doing when
you're directing a scene I think and
every every actor you have a different
kind of relationship with and work
differently with within within the scene
sometimes so you just have to kind of
figure out how you best communicate with
with your actor our second day of
shooting was the scene where we had to
do the slot where Linda comes home later
than her curfew and mom was there at the
door to slap her and we had a stunt
coordinator that was going to coordinate
this lap and Sharon said uh-uh we have
to slap her you know we have we have to
do this I was dragged across the room by
Joe Pesci and thrown down the stairs by
I may have the order wrong but Sharon
and her exactitude said no we have to do
this and of course she was right and I
said to Sharon come here slap me and
shout when whack and I said okay just
don't hit her on the nose so I can
forever say it was slapped by Sharon
Stone and actually he said what would
that be like and I went it would be like
this but it made all the difference in
the scene she added pretty dark some
pretty dark experiences that I just I
didn't feel I needed to see
but but I did I actually did watch about
15 10 15 minutes a deep throat until I
was just so bored and and then I saw all
the footage just on a loop just of her
Phil Donahue I mean I actually had it to
to recreate that completely it's still
plays in my mind's entire scene
performing against a green screen yeah
there was no real Phil Donahue there's a
guy with a white hair who would move his
head bobble his head as if he's because
he you saw the back of him as he's
talking it was so bizarre but I it was
so ingrained in my memory that Phil
Donahue episode that I just I was able
to get there it's weird but yeah there
there there's a lot there really is if
you're looking for it you can find it on
the Internet it's the most amazing tool
for an actor and as soon as I read the
script I was like I need to I need to
know everything about this woman it's a
really tragic story but it is really
fascinating and it is kind of uplifting
and the fact that she did find her voice
after all that after everything she went
through she found she figured out who
she was and she found her own identity
and she just tried to kind of prove to
the world who she really was
you know she spoke out about what
happened to her in the face of really a
lot of skepticism which which you know
we wanted to we wanted to show in the
Donahue's scene those obviously those
are real people doubting her and you
know the doubting never stopped and she
never you know she was never she never
got defensive about it she was just
always well I understand how you know
you find it difficult to believe but
this is what happened and I found that
very impressive